my name is at CBS Allah and come from
Japan came University
I like talking on visualization
mathematical visualization and how to
work on the complex to me
okay first of all we want to change the
title like this because some people
recently the copper sheet doesn't work
well but anyway some people recently
pointed out non topological is not maybe
misleading so we'll change this instead
from now on so in this talk we focus on
high dimensional mathematical
visualizations in a figurative manner
rather than abstract son before starting
our discussion I'll show you what we
want to emphasize throughout the
presentation it is apparently believed
that the answers to various problems of
basic math consisting of elementary
calculus and geometry and faced by high
school or junior high school and college
students have already been well
established and there might be not any
room for further study or discussion but
actually any unfixed holes pitfalls
found almost everywhere in this area
especially when it comes to graphing
functions to understand their behavior
in higher dimensional space that we can
neither experienced nor access directory
so last year we discussed this matter
with the people at SIGGRAPH Asia and in
Bangkok held in Bangkok and noticed that
although our research work was based on
several simple facts I didn't seem to be
as simple to understand
okay here's ok so before proceeding to
that slide
recently Nobel Prize winner said that do
not trust words written in text books a
guy who follow him
this gender okay so I'll explain it to
you about this one by one okay
so first one is okay my okay my code my
problem is is Raja I'm not smart so you
can make it a more compact okay so
please allow me and seeds so this show
you how to locate and let's look at the
root of the quadratic equation to
construct a graph of a complex quadratic
function the horizontal plane is used
for as XY plane of the domain okay and
vertical axis through the origin on this
plane is assigned to the real part for
example the rear part of the range you
for you is greater than one a number of
parabola is drawn as a graph restricted
in the x-values space and for you less
than one an inverted parabola orthogonal
to both XY and XY plane is drawn and
this parabola intersects except plane at
the two points okay press minus I which
is the imaginary root of the given
equation notice these points are actual
points and there is no need to imagine
them with this type of visualization
this Pettersson visualization method was
first introduced in 1945 this by America
and high school math teacher back in
1945 okay this is amazing fact and
surprisingly it is still not popular
even after a 73 years since then this is
a bit strange to me
another example is this one relating to
a project by geometry
here there's a there's a column called
between two intersecting circles right
that's at the left but okay so we get a
we get a common core's equation is
calculated by subtracting okay between
these two circles equation so strangely
there's a the this this formula are C 1
minus C 2 still exist when there's no
intersection between two circles so
postre pointed out this so this fact
that continuity principle he stated the
continuity principle state that if a
certain number of solutions are expected
then they'll always be the same number
of solutions or get unchanged the number
of solutions are unchanged or example or
this two circles intersect in two points
so it can be stated at every two circles
intersect in two points although the
points may be imaginary or may coincide
so we can see this what is happening
what's really happening is okay just
just adding more one dimension to this
to this chart so you can see okay the
left you can see that two intersection
points and but okay Sakho itself is you
know in a complex domain you know it
always accompanied by a two hyperbola at
the end two ends so the combination of
one circle and the two parabola we call
it our complexify the circle so if that
there's there's no intersection but
intersection is there between that two
hyperbolas okay so okay while we stay
over sized
figurative so the term figurative refers
to any form of mathematical
visualization that retains strong
references to the geometry found in the
real world
so although topological abstraction
plays are exceptionally important role
in modern mathematics I know I know that
but it can greatly reduce the amount of
information to towards needed for the
problem to be just identified and
sometimes led to a lot of misconceptions
that's my concern
so rather than such abstraction
processes we advocate the figurative
approaches are often considered as prime
solution candidates for example we can
understand the meaning of this formula
in the yellow ones okay this seems
rather complicated at first sight but
very easily and intuitively from the
visualization result I will show you so
this this inverse hyperbolic cosine
function so here okay so any functions
graph in a competence domain is a it's a
two-dimensional surface in the four
dimensional space as you know so we can
depict that what happening okay there
are two ways to is calculating the
cross-section or shadow you see this one
is a cross section you will see this
okay the black one is a sine curve and
we can see the cosine hyperbolic cosine
the blue ones and red ones means means
sine hyperbolic all these functions are
closely related or in other words a part
of the graph or a different cut of the
same graph
so we can construct a serious you
correcting the shuttle of the two
dimension to two-dimensional surface in
the four dimension space to a three
dimensional space we that we are living
in okay you can try this program using
my notebook see so what I want to say is
which is traditionally traditionally
this cosine function or because I have a
break function okay to recommend
trigonometric functions and then the hi
public function is a same identical in a
complex complex to me okay no not at
brothers or not not sisters okay they
are identical so the cosine functions
through riemann surface of the cosine
function is is a traditionally drawn in
this abstract a forum so notice okay we
have nothing from this abstract chart
but but by looking this shadow to top
okay looking look at this by looking
this a shadow so we see that okay inside
the root x square my son excuse me x
square minus 1 or we can deform as X
plus 1 by X minus 1 so we can get that
to branch point at 's equal minus 1 and
is equal to plus 1 okay so notice ok
this is a typical example so the
figurative approach to mathematics
visualizations work well works well
completely well so that ok localism this
as you know
the riemann surface of rügen is a
infinite spiral staircase right
so within it so this this shadow means
so the formula presents that the riemann
surface of the inverse hyperbolic cosine
function can be constructed by piling up
the riemann surface of the square root
at the bust points x minus ax equal
equal minus 1 and X equal 1 or X or Z Z
equal minus 1 and Z equal 1 along the
ap2 spiral staircase that exactly what
this formula means so so now move to a
different world
so so far we look at mathematical
visualization a rather traditional way
but you know in an info based world
information visualization world there's
a one expert
Tamara Munson our said that ok what is
the most important most important point
in the info base she stated that she
said it a very a number of useful things
but she stated that ok algorithm are
waiting for report reproducing or
validation process the our business is
very important or any ok formula or
expressed by the equations that's a just
a point for validation or reproducing
process so one day one day I asked this
these kind of things to to one famous
mathematics professor at my university
he goes this only equations can prove
theorems
right so we don't mind even though the
visuals are incomplete I'm very shocked
to hear that you know and okay so
visualization process is okay it's not
indispensable so I realized for the
first time okay that this means the
mathematical visualization may be left
incomplete yes we found it we found the
example this one okay what does the
remus appears I exist and for C this is
the most popular figure appeared in
every primer on complex analysis okay
there are tons of tons of complex
analysis our complex functions book
right on this planet but no one no one
nothing nobody says explain to me
okay this axis is mean actually mean
nobody this is very strange is real
strange but it reasonable okay I will
show you so a Riemann sphere it's no
Marie describes as a real number line
that is complexify the first and then
projective iced or a compact
compactified so and in addition to this
there are other strange things coming up
here here there's a okay the stage is is
a you know complex domain and at the
same time in a projective space at the
same we have to consider to those things
at the same time simultaneously okay so
how to construct the projective space I
will show it as chart you know we we
know already know the recurrence
relation between those projective spaces
from the dimension 0 right so okay
starting from studying for the point
point at oh one zero
and okay number line as the cross at I
set the one of the another dimension and
and so on
and okay so number line we can make
number line to a to a half circle that
means projected biased and a
compactified and then we will get Sarco
whole circle as our p1 so this is this
[Music]
okay in this case again no book provide
us with a comprehensive pictures okay so
some of the related things here are
constructing the riemann surface of the
complex third function now for example a
root function around it's a singular
point in okay okay traditionally
traditionally traditionally those
pictures are written written by hand I
don't call it any guess crippled or
graffiti or I don't I don't I don't
think so but okay handwritten chart are
dominated so I think it's not not good
in some some sense so I I tried in back
in 1982 to draw in I am using I was
using them mini-computer dec 20 2014 2
to move the moving objects or at the
real time okay so another trial is done
by okay so before that case you see this
is a cold to depicts Riemann surface in
the surface of the root function Oh
whoa what's going on anyway please try
by yourself
okay just to see any sort of functions
mainly so another trial famous one is
done by a doctor bunch of Thomas Paine
shot in this book is written in 1990
great contributions done by mr. a doctor
maker trot one of the genius here in a
group from research to making a number
of great jobs and I respect him too much
okay so these okay so now we're back to
a back to a first question okay so what
is what its access actually means so it
is it is it is one of the range or you
are a V of the complex function no no
this Riemann sphere is a domain of the
function
there is projective eyes and then
compactified so range or Co domain has
no relationship or space so other
question is the solution candidate is
the axis of one which we use when we
define some homogeneous coordinate but
but we still have a question other
questions but in this case it is strange
that axes is a one-dimensional
okay so it must have at least two
dimensional and a real part or imaginary
part so what should we do so anyway okay
so and this recurrence relation formula
is a Oh
five more times okay
so let's look at my notebook after that
so move on to other choice uh another
demonstration oh [ __ ]
so so then okay we can see the the
Riemann sphere is identical to severe
anyway but it is derived from the
complexified circle the question is
question is there's any relation to
between this complex force our core and
the severe so we were sure this this
movie we can see you see okay in an
immersive environment immersive
environment so we are stepping in to
last origin there is no it is not
prohibited to step into because it means
the origin is zero divided by zero so we
can see okay these two textures on a
tool objects so meet together gradually
grievers so we can see the homeomorphism
homomorphic between two two objects some
of you may say that this is obvious this
is a tautology from the we can easily
proved by the formula but we can
experience from this immersive
environment to this homeomorphism are
more intuitively understand okay thank
you so that's the final one we're making
this kind of research and okay proceed
to another step towards okay now at this
point we can feel that that the true
cars of the CP one so we we have to move
on to the CP 2
thank you very much
[Applause]